cyan magenta and yellow  subtractive color mixing  i worked with the inventors of the  original cmy cube to make this special  edition which curiosity box subscribers  will be receiving in the spring the cyan  face filters out long wavelengths while  the yellow filters out short ones  together only the greens in the middle  of the visible spectrum get through  magenta blocks the middle of the  spectrum so paired with cyan only short  wavelength blues and purples come  through and paired with yellow just the  long reds and oranges emerge it's not  too late to get this and more go to  curiositybox.com  to join and thank you for supporting  smart toys a good cause and for feeding  your brain